today on the matt welsh show leftists
scream out in abject terror as elon musk
completes his purchase of twitter we
will revel in their despair today also
as my children's book johnny the walrus
is finally released we'll take a look at
the horrifying children's book that is
currently the best seller in the
category it's written by the american
academy of pediatrics
and if you've been paying attention you
know that that's a very bad sign plus a
boy physically assaults a girl at a high
school in atlanta but the students are
taking the boy's side because the girl
used a naughty word apparently and in
our daily cancellation rolling stone has
a glowing profile of furries who are
sexually attracted to cartoon animals
all of that and more today on the matt
walsh show
[Music]
values are now up 19
these gains have become an important
financial tool for homeowners because
you're able to access the equity as cash
at incredibly low interest rates this
makes it easier to pay off high interest
debt fund home renovations or do
whatever you need because it's your
money now if this sounds like something
you're interested in it's worth a call
to american financing to learn more
because they're going to provide a free
mortgage review so you can understand
your options before moving forward
there's no pressure there's no upfront
or hidden fees
that's not what they do at american
financing instead they take the time to
get to know you so they can find the
perfect loan to achieve your goals it
could mean savings of up to twelve
thousand dollars a year plus tens of
thousands long term and you're going to
get all of that uh when you call 866
569-4711 you got to take advantage of
this deal right now and call
866-569-4711
or if you don't want to call you can
always visit americanfinancing.net
american financing nmls
182-334-nmlsconsumeraccess.org
so yesterday the sun
went dark the earth shook and trembled
fire raged across the land consuming all
in its wake the screams of the forsaken
masses could be heard rising up with the
smoke horror of horrors the ultimate
nightmare
had come to pass
elon musk
taking control of twitter
the twitter corporate board had for so
many years before this
hugged twitter's users tightly against
its bosom protecting them and rocking
them softly to sleep each night but that
was all over uh yesterday
it abandoned them abandoned us all to
the cold in the night where there will
be wailing and gnashing of teeth and
lots of memes also presumably twitter
has officially accepted elon musk's
offer to buy the company for 43 billion
dollars
now tragically the company will be run
by a billionaire as opposed to before
when it was run by
different billionaires elizabeth warren
made a good point when she tweeted
yesterday
this deal is dangerous for our democracy
billionaires like elon musk play by a
different set of rules than everybody
else accumulating power for their own
gain we need a wealth tax and strong
rules to hold big tech accountable
yes it is dangerous to have a
billionaire in charge of a social media
platform that's why those of us who are
so upset by this turn of events and who
absolutely refuse to use a site that is
owned by a billionaire now must
deactivate our accounts
and give all of our business to facebook
and instagram and tick tock instead
you know the ones that aren't run by
billionaires
but i think the real question that we
all face now is how do we explain this
to our children
you know i've already had the difficult
conversation last night as i was
weeping in the living room which is my
usual nightly routine of course my
three-year-old pangender child moonbeam
came in and asked matt
with elon musk taking over twitter will
hate speech be normalized
is our democracy in grave peril
is our country on the verge of
destruction is life even worth living
anymore
and i look back at them and answered yes
yes yes
and no
and then we simply held each other and
sobbed uncontrollably
it was sad yet beautiful
a beautiful moment with me and moonshine
or whatever my fake kid's name is in
this joke to be honest originally i'd
plan to keep the sarcasm going for the
entire opening monologue but then i
realized that that would deprive me of
the opportunity to gloat more openly and
blatantly
which is what i really want to do so
i'll switch gears here and instead i'll
let um the libs speak for themselves
fortunately uh nazi propagandist libs of
tick tock has compiled a few authentic
lib reactions to the news from tiktok
and um well here's how they're taking it
[Applause]
you know they really make some good
points actually
it would
possibly be slightly easier to
understand if we listen to them one at a
time though so uh let's do that instead
well
it looks like twitter's gone they
accepted the money
and elon stalin is taking over so [ __ ]
you twitter and goodbye forever you
insane cue like
forum
or soon to be insane like you like forum
peace out bye
elon musk
this is directly to you
enjoy twitter i just deactivated mine i
will not be reactivating it
enjoy
i deactivated my account and deleted the
app
that's what i think of it
elon musk
today twitter has announced that they've
been bought by
elon musk or
however you say his name um
i'm not interested in staying on twitter
anymore because of this and i think
there's a lot of people that are about
to leave
so i just wanted to
let everyone know that you can find me
here i'm gonna also share this on
twitter before i deactivate my account
so that anyone who wants to follow me
can find me here as well
hey
i did a thing today
i deactivated my twitter account
you can too
on second thought that wasn't much more
coherent i suppose though i'm sure elon
musk is devastated by the incisive
searing wit of these tick-tock libs i'm
not sure how he'll ever recover from you
know things like elon stalin
uh indeed i i bet he's now rethinking
the whole thing now that we've learned
that at tammy clove at queenie bella and
aft at snurfyboo are leaving the site
i was one of the users there on tick
tock snurfy boo
look a twitter without snurfyboo is just
not the same
on the plus side however race hustler
sean king actually did deactivate his
account nearly as soon as the news was
announced and that alone is worth 43
billion dollars
many other prominent leftists vowed to
leave the platform though most of them
appear to still be on the platform as of
this morning i mean
some of these a lot of these people have
been tweeting over and over and over
again about how they're not going to use
the platform anymore
and yet they're still using it to talk
about how they're not going to use it
perhaps their accounts merely identify
as deactivated i don't know another
common complaint has been that elon musk
is uh spending his money on buying
twitter when he could be using it to end
world hunger you know because world
hunger is all his fault john fuglesang
tweeted for 44 billion dollars a guy
could have gone down in history for
ending world hunger history will record
that our mega billionaires had other
priorities
now funny i don't remember those kinds
of criticisms when jeff bezos used his
money to buy the washington post
but the criticisms
would have been stupid in that case also
because in fact um even the richest men
in the world don't have enough money to
end world hunger there is no amount of
money that could wipe out world hunger i
if i had 10 trillion dollars
to dedicate to wiping out world hunger
there would still be world hunger even
after the 10 trillion is spent or rather
wasted
because a lot of the hunger in the world
is due not to a simple lack of resources
but to corrupt and incompetent
governments and regimes throwing money
at that problem isn't going to solve it
in fact many times it could make it a
lot worse as we have seen time and time
and time again
meanwhile groups like human rights watch
and the aclu are raising different
concerns they're issuing dire warnings
about the epidemic of hate speech that
may now be coming for us
and coming to twitter because of elon
musk
these worries were echoed all over cable
news especially by brian stelter listen
to this
if you
uh
if you get invited to something where
there are no rules where there is total
freedom forever everybody do you
actually want to go to that party or are
you gonna decide to stay home and that's
a question for twitter users some
twitter users might love the idea
there's gonna be absolutely no
moderation and no rules at all others
might not want to be anywhere near that
am i am i crazy matt no no you're right
and what what happens to the advertising
i mean if there's no moderation or
little moderation do the advertisers
stay away what does that do to the
business prospects for twitter itself
there's just something perfect about
this because i can totally imagine brian
stelter standing outside of a party and
saying excuse me i need to know the
ground rules for this party before i
come in
do you have the rules posted anywhere
i want to make sure everyone is
following the rules
this isn't one of those parties without
rules is it and everybody inside the
party will just look at him and say uh
you weren't invited brian
what are you doing here
stop hiding in the bushes you're weirdo
go home
of course uh minor detail here stelter
is lying obviously musk has never said
that there will be no moderation at all
i mean that's that's the thing about all
this this panicking oh he's going to get
rid of the rules he actually never said
he was going to do that
but it is fascinating to see the
evolution the left has gone from the
counter culture
to the hall monitors pushing up their
glasses and you know prattling on about
the rules
the left you know they're now the kid in
your class who reminds the teacher to
give out the homework assignment they're
that kid over on msnbc they're raising
concerns that sound
somehow oddly familiar listen
you own all of twitter or facebook or
what have you
you don't have to explain yourself you
don't even have to be transparent you
could secretly ban
one party's candidate or all of its
candidates
all of its nominees or you could just
secretly turn down the reach of their
stuff and turn up the reach of something
else and the rest of us might not even
find out about it till after the
election
elon musk says this is all to help
people because he is just a free speech
philosophically clear open-minded helper
yes wouldn't it be terrible if that
happened i mean just imagine allow
yourself to entertain this crazy
hypothetical where big tech companies
target people based on their politics
and censor information in order to
influence the outcome of an election
just imagine that
of course you don't have to imagine it
you already lived through it
conservatives have experienced exactly
that sort of thing for years and despite
what this guy at msnbc might say the
fact is that elon musk has made no
indication that he's going to put the
shoe on the other foot and start
censoring and stifling leftist speech in
that way
as satisfying as that might be from a
vengeance perspective
but he's not going to do that and they
know he's not going to do that
musk has shown no inclinations in that
direction
what they're worried about is exactly
what brian stelter said and what the
aclu
and various pseudo-human rights groups
are now fretting about
they're panicking not over the
possibility that speech will be stifled
but over the threat that it will no
longer be stifled
for years they insisted that
conservative speech was not being
censored or suppressed now they're
running around like their hair is on
fire uh well brian stelter is running
around like his hair is on fire but you
know you know i'm saying uh because
conservative speech will no longer be
censored and suppressed so you know how
quickly we went from
that isn't happening to
that is happening and actually it's good
and it has to keep happening
we've seen this kind of transition
countless times
and now we're seeing it finally with the
issue of free speech
where we went from
free speech isn't under attack you
conspiracy theorists
to actually free speech is bad and
should be under attack
another viral leftist reaction to the
musk news uh makes this point i think
very clear listen to this
are you concerned about the rise of
american fascism well today
you can be more concerned uh it's almost
certain that with this move trump is
going to come back to social media i
mean this has so many horrific
implications i'm not even sure where to
start to be completely honest with you
there is a problem with this idea of
free speech and that is where is the
limit free speech has the ability to
incite some really horrific and hateful
things like for instance an insurrection
if this
owns twitter the world is going to be a
much worse place and it's not just him
this is a problem across social media
but certainly this isn't making the
problem better anyway i imagine there's
going to be a mass exodus from twitter
in fact newsweek even posted how to
delete your twitter account an hour ago
i didn't have a twitter account ever
until i joined this app to go and look
at news and stuff so it's not that bad
you know not having one i just have a
very strong feeling that the extremism
on the right is going to get more
significant after this
yes we have to censor speech
in order to avoid fascism
see how that works
where are the limits to free speech he
asks what are the limits
and he provides the answer they all
provide the answer
all opinions that differ from his own
are beyond the limits or ought to be
so they've dropped the act almost at
least for now they've dropped it
this um internet the internet is a party
with rules they say and the rules are
that one side doesn't get to speak
or those were the rules
now the left at least on one platform
will have to figure out how to engage
with opposing ideas or at a minimum
tolerate them
and if they can't do that and they
certainly can't do that then they'll
just have to make do with the platforms
that still censor their opponents and
welcome their speech um and welcome only
their speech so in other words every
other platform on the internet pretty
much is what they'll have to make do
with
somehow i think they'll survive
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know it's always a great idea to
keep learning new skills and the copy is
telling me to riff about skills i'd like
to learn but really that's hard for me
to do because i have zero skills at all
so really any ski i'd like to learn any
skill
whatsoever
and uh if you're in that boat or if you
have some skills we want to learn a few
more if you're always learning it keeps
you sharp like zip recruiter their ai is
always learning so if you're hiring
their ai gets better and faster at
finding the right candidates for all of
your roles and right now you could try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com walsh
zippercutter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates with your job then it
proactively presents these candidates to
you you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job so
this is the proactive thing that you're
doing you're not just throwing the it
out there into the ether and hoping that
somebody finds it um and this is why zip
recruiter is the number one rated hiring
site in the us based on g2 ratings and
now you can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com walsh that's
ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
i can tell you um if if i'm elon musk
here's my agenda coming in the door
first of all i'm gonna investigate all
of the censorship and the dishonest
practices in the past and reveal all of
it
um because it's it's good to come in and
clean up shop but we also need to know
what happened before that's the that's
one of the best things about elon musk
taking over is that he's going to have
access to all that information now we're
going to know for sure
the things that we already know happened
now we're going to have
the the proof of it we're going to see
it all
in
in writing probably
and you know there need to be there need
to be reparations even there should be
reparation
programs for conservatives on twitter to
make up for what we experience then i'm
going to um if i'm formula musk i would
just fire almost everybody and hire all
new people because you're going to need
to do that
and um
you know it's quite revealing actually
that the reports are now that the
twitter after they after they announced
the sale of twitter they've shut down
um
a lot of the functionality behind the
scenes so that changes can't be made
because they're worried about their own
employees sabotaging the platforms that
tells you that tells you what they know
about their employees so if you're elon
musk coming in you've got to just
basically fire everybody
and then
make the algorithms public which he's
already said he would do
make them totally transparent
and then also if i'm elon musk i'm going
to hire the host of the matt wall show
and the daily wire as the new chief
diversity officer that's probably that's
probably in fact priority number one
so i'm still waiting to get the call
from elon musk
all right let's start with this you know
it's a tough week for um
our dear friends on the left for the
reasons we've just reviewed
and at insult to injury um my
best-selling lgbt children's book is
finally being released you know we
announced the book a few months ago they
sold out in less than a day we had to
print a whole new batch and um those new
books are shipping out today and the
good news is also that you can buy the
book today and you won't have to wait
months for it to come if you can believe
it or not you could just buy it it'll
come like the next day or two days from
now
we have copies available for purchase a
lot of copies and this this all presents
a wonderful opportunity for us
because johnny the walrus my book about
a young boy who identifies as a walrus
has already been as you may have heard a
best-selling children's book
best-selling lgbt book best-selling book
overall
but let us just imagine together let us
picture the possibility
that
we get it charting as a bestseller again
this week amid everything else that's
happening
i think we can do that together and we
must
especially
when you consider what is currently
what what current what books are
currently charting as bestsellers on
amazon um one of the top books and in
fact this was the number one children's
book overall on amazon yesterday now i
think it's dropped down slightly it's in
the top five
but this is a book that was just
released it's called uology a puberty
guide for everybody now this book is if
you're wondering
who published it this is a book
published by the american academy of
pediatrics
all right so it's not even just one
wacky left-wing writer this is the
american academy of pediatrics and they
publish this book on uh
on puberty
and this is how bad it's gotten that
you already know what's what's in this
book you already know that it's bad
because the american academy of
pediatrics is behind it and the subject
is puberty
so just to give you an idea um there's a
chapter in this book
one of the best-selling children's books
on amazon which is being marketed to
kids 9 through 12.
and there's a chapter called
when puberty doesn't feel
and
right
just going to read a little bit of this
chapter to you
because this is a this is a book that um
that nine-year-olds are going to be
reading
and i guarantee you given the fact that
this is that this is published by the
american academy of pediatrics it's
going to be in schools
and if anybody complains about it the
schools are going to say what do you
have a problem with science and medicine
it's the american academy of pediatrics
it's as mainstream as you could possibly
get
well here's what it says
chapter 12 when
puberty doesn't feel right
it says and then it kind of starts with
a little story about a girl named kimmy
quinn jasmine nancy and i are getting
ready for bed stepping around the
sleeping bags that form a circle on
nancy's bedroom floor i take my pajamas
to the corner and turn my back to the
others as i change quinn is changing at
the same time and isn't paying attention
and jasmine is looking for something in
her bag but then nancy looks over at me
right as i'm changing my shirt i try to
cover my chest and nancy looks away
quickly but i know she saw my flat chest
nancy says i still have a super flat
chest too i can't wait to finally start
puberty i hate blooming so much later
than everybody else
i finish putting on my pajamas and then
i take a deep breath
my body will never grow breasts on its
own because i'm trans i say looking at
nancy until she meets my eyes
but it's something that i have options
for and that i talk with my doctors
about
uh then it goes on thanks for telling us
we won't tell anyone else quinn says
then quinn explains that they don't
identify as a boy or a girl so they know
what it's like to get questions about
gender expectations
i talk with my doctor about being
non-binary too
it's nice to have somebody who can help
my parents and me figure out what's
going to work best for my body okay so
in this
i have to keep repeating book by the
american academy pediatrics
if you think you can still trust
doctors in the medical profession
you can't
period you especially can't trust them
with your kid and that's just i wish
that was not the case
um
because i because i understand the
implications of saying that you just
cannot trust the medical profession
anymore
at all but you can't
because
this is what you're getting from them
um
and
already in this we've got a story about
the sleepover with with little girls and
in this sleepover they're telling us
about um
one of the girls is trans and one is
non-binary
it's got a small collection of girls and
two of them are at least two
are um
in that category
which which actually
accurately reflects
the situation that our daughters are in
and that they face socially
that's how prevalent this stuff is
in fact if you send your daughter to a
sleepover with five other girls
there's a statistically almost it's
almost certain statistically that one of
them is gonna then at least one will
identify as trans or non-binary or
whatever else
um
and then um continues we have this
fun fact
um
doctors can put puberty on pause
that's true doctors can prescribe
medicine to stop puberty temporarily
but they do that only for important
reasons
early puberty can cause emotional and
physical problems for very young
children it can be difficult for very
young kids to manage puberty and early
puberty can stunt their growth for those
reasons doctors may use medication to
cause puberty then when a child is older
they can stop the medicine and puberty
will begin again at that point puberty
will progress normally like it does for
others
some people refer to these medications
as puberty blockers but really they
don't block puberty forever they just
put puberty on pause
and then it says just not feeling right
sometimes puberty can start right on
time but the changes happening on the
outside the body don't truly feel right
sure lots of kids might feel a little
weird or uncomfortable about their
changing body but for some kids it's not
just strange or new for some the changes
on the outside the body don't fit with
the way they feel on the inside or for
some the outside changes feel completely
wrong
and so they mentioned precocious puberty
as a reason for puberty blockers but
then they get to well yes but there are
plenty of cases where it's not
precocious puberty everything is is
physically normal with puberty but it
just doesn't feel right
and so that's when they put you on the
drugs
that they claim in this book just pause
puberty and then they pick it up
right back up again and there's no
problems there's no long-term um uh
health complications or anything which
is a total lie and of course the
american
academy pediatrics they know that's not
true
but this is what they're telling not
just to parents about their kids but
they're telling this to kids
that you might want to use puberty
blockers if it just doesn't feel right
well that's
that's um
that's quite a thing to say to kids
because
every kid going through puberty will at
least have a season where it doesn't
quite feel right
that's going to happen to every kid
in fact every person
you know given the fact that we're
mortal beings and we don't we we do not
have
absolute control over our bodies and in
fact we have no control over the natural
processes that our bodies
undergo and growing and changing all
that stuff we have little to no control
over most of that
and so everybody
has times where you feel like you're
you're almost at war with your own body
you know
and um
when you when you go to kids and you
tell them and you give them a way of
understanding this and you tell them
that oh well if it doesn't feel right
you could just stop it that's always an
option
and there are no side effects there are
no complications there's no problem just
take the pills and stop it
when you tell it to kids you're going to
find a whole lot of kids
all of a sudden lining up for puberty
blockers that's exactly what's happening
because of books like this
so all the more reason um to go to
johnnywalrus.com or go to amazon.com
get my book at least over this this uh
filth
okay let's go here next uh this is a
story we're gonna play this this is a
news clip from wsb in atlanta um
there's a controversy a
protest at this high school in atlanta
um
after a
after
a male a boy
physically assaulted a girl
and now there are protests
but who do you think the protests are on
behalf of whose side do you think the
protesters are taking in this i don't
think you'll be shocked to discover but
let's watch a little bit of this news
report
new video at 5 shows a male student
slapping a female student after she
called him the n-word this led to a
walkout at locust grove high school and
channel 2's audrey washington is live in
henry county audrey students are upset
about the different punishments given to
these students
right and it's important to note that
they believe both students were wrong
but they don't believe both students
were punished equally so they walked out
of class here and protested right there
inside locust grove high
they chanted black lives matter as they
walked out of classes here at locust
grove high it just bothered me because i
didn't stand up before and i thought
this is the perfect time for me to stand
up now high school senior leila moreau
helped organize the protest this week
she says it was in response to what
happened in this video and what happened
afterwards a student shared the video
with me on friday we blurred the faces
of the kids involved but in the video
you see a white female student call
another black male student the n word
next you see the boy walk up to the girl
and slap her both students were
disciplined but those who protested told
me they believe while both students were
wrong they were not punished equally she
got to go to class and get her education
while he had to leave for his education
he was only defending him so pause it
there for a second
let's pause it right there
uh this is
if look a lot of the reactions on social
media and of course the race hustlers
the prominent
race hustlers have gotten involved in
this
um i don't know if al sharpton has
showed up yet but i'm sure he will who's
the other guy the new al sharpton ben
crump
is uh he's always pair he parachutes
down as soon as something like that he's
on the scene so he's probably already
there as far as i know
and this is um this is the narrative
that you're they're hearing that in fact
the boy was acting in self-defense we
just heard that from the student there
who organized this protest and these
were this is a mass protest of people
marching through the halls shouting
black lives matter
and
the narrative is that he was just
defending himself
defending himself
now you could see in the video you've
got the
a girl
sitting off to the side
in the gym
far away from the boy she shouts
apparently a racial slur
that's bad you shit's a bad word and you
should not use that bad word
um
in fact uh kids in school shouldn't be
using any bad words
very often they do i'm told but they
shouldn't and so we should be very clear
to to the kids we don't use bad words
that's a bad word you don't you don't
use it
and i'm also fine with punishing kids
who use
bad words
i think we ought to do that
but she's off to the side sitting down
she's also a girl
and she shouts this word he walks over
to her
and smacks her in the face assaulter
physically assaults her
is a boy physically assaulting a girl he
was defending himself was was his
physical safety in jeopardy in any way
whatsoever
from the from the girl who said
something to him and he had to walk
across the gym to confront her over it
defending himself
well no of course his his physical
safety was not in jeopardy whatsoever
i mean if she had gone over
and used that word or not used it
and then and then physically attacked
him
and he hit her back and as a means of
getting her off you know defending
himself getting her off of him
be a different story that's not what
happened
so no this is not physical self-defense
this is um but what we know what we've
seen from the left
is that depending on your demographics
this is all this is all demographic
dependent but
if you fall into the right victim
group
and if all the intersectional points
work out in your favor
then you know you can use physical
violence to
defend your psychological well-being
so she didn't physically attack him but
she she used a word
that might emotionally or
psychologically hurt him
even though i can guarantee he he hears
that word from his friends
all the time
and there's a very high likelihood that
he uses it himself
but he heard the word from someone with
a lighter skin color and so that is
psychologically damaging to him and so
he can use physical violence to defend
his psychological well-being that's
that's the logic here
and if there's something else and this
should already be entirely clear to you
but
if it wasn't this should make it even
more clear um that if you're a woman
on the left
um
you have been your your victim points
you know on the victim hierarchy you've
been
you're all the way down the ladder
it didn't used to be that way
there was a time when you were a little
bit higher up toward towards the the
pinnacle as a chief victim
and uh especially around that we got to
the metoo movement and so that was
trendy for a while and uh so you know
all you just just being a woman afforded
you a whole bunch of victim points and
put you above
almost everybody else on the victim
pyramid but now you're all the way at
the bottom
i mean you're not quite at the level of
being a white male but you're you're
just barely above that
and what that means is that you could be
physically assaulted
and uh
everybody will take the other person's
side
let's keep watching a little bit of this
report here
reached out to henry county schools
about the incident and the disciplinary
allegations a school district
representative said in part quote we
can't share disciplinary action for
students due to student privacy both
students were disciplined based on their
code of conduct infractions the
representative went on to state school
leaders have been working with and
listening to any students who needed to
express their feelings or concerns on
the matter the school day is progressing
with administrators continuing to be
available for any student who needs to
talk layla says she's been called a
racial slur at the school before and
wants the school district to do more i
just want some change i want them to i'm
just tired of the inequality in the
school
now we still don't know what exactly led
up to the initial incident as for what
happens next students here told me they
will be setting up a special black
student organization here at the school
that's a part of the story i'm working
on for channel 2 action news at 6. right
now we are live here in locust grove
henry county audrey washington channel 2
action news
uh setting up a group and and when we
set up the group of course the the
number one priority the number one uh uh
principle is that if you're a black
person you're allowed to commit physical
violence if you don't like a word
um and that is
that is quite literally
the position the left takes on this
that if you are a black person you can
commit physical violence in response to
a naughty word
that uh hurt your feelings and but
that principle does not extend
to other demographic groups
it it goes without saying that if you're
a white person
and a black person uses a word to you
even a racist word that you don't like
you of course cannot hit them for that
that's crazy you can't hit somebody
because they said a word
no that is a that's a privilege that
extends
only to racial minorities not to white
people and that is their actual position
that they
take the students say that oh it's a
it's unfair because there was unequal
punishment
yeah well sane common sense adults
know or should know
that yeah well you have an unequal
punishment because these were unequal
infractions
one is a naughty word the other is
physical violence
but when you filter it through identity
politics all of that becomes twisted
upside down and backwards and everything
else
guys from cnbc it says throughout the
pandemic many adults turn to a likely
safety net their parents from buying
food to paying for their cell phone
plans or covering health and auto
returns
half of parents with a child over 18
provide them with at least some
financial support according to report by
savings.com these parents are shelling
out roughly a thousand dollars a month
on average on such expenses the report
found
young adults just starting out have
faced significant financial hurdles over
the last few years including an uneven
job market the hefty student loan bills
from schools and soaring housing costs
and so now
the the news is that half of
parents with adult children are
providing them with financial support
now the thing about that is
you know on one hand
this is this is how it should work
like i would much rather hear that
parents are providing financial
assistance to their kids then their kids
are getting financial assistance from
the government you know you should be
it's going to family members to help you
out when you're in a tight spot that's
how that's supposed to work is what
families are supposed to do for each
other and it's good to have that
have that kind of have that sort of
that's the safety net
that should be in place
that's the way it ought to work
rather than having government provide a
safety net for 330 million people
um that costs billions or trillions
rather trillions of dollars to maintain
the safety net should be in your own
family so that is how that's supposed to
work
and you know i don't have adult kids yet
but
when i'm
you know when my kids are adults if they
fall on financial hard times it's hard
for me to see
me not giving them some help not not
helping them out just as i would do and
have done for other members of of
the family you know who are adults
the problem though
is
when the adult children
and now we start putting emphasis on
children
begin to depend on that become dependent
and feel entitled to it
and then this kind of uh intersects with
what we talked about last week where
we've got among millennials in gen z
uh there's a you know a large number of
them that if they're feeling
unhappy in a job they're just not having
fun they're not feeling feeling
fulfilled well they'll just they'll quit
the job because they're not having fun
and that raised the question last week
that we talked about which is well how
could you possibly afford
how could you afford to just quit your
job because you're not having fun doing
it
well this is part of the stories that
then they go to their parents
who
um
oftentimes unfortunately are more than
willing to to fund that kind of
lifestyle
so this is if if people could just
exercise a little bit of responsibility
and common sense
then that would solve a lot of these
problems
like in in principle there's obviously
nothing wrong
with a parent helping out their kid when
they're in when they when they've hit
hard times obviously
um
it's just that there's no moderation or
common sense
anymore and so that turns into okay i'm
going to fund my adult child's
lazy lifestyle for the next 10 years
while they just sit around and don't
even attempt to go and get a job or
anything else
that's when it crosses the line this is
from the daily wires this is a story
from a couple days ago that i wanted to
i just wanted to touch on representative
madison cawthorne responded friday to a
report that showed him wearing lingerie
by explaining the alleged context
surrounding the photos so these were
photos that went viral on twitter
last week as madison cawthorne of course
he's a republican representative and and
uh he's one of the one one that the the
left
among
in the group that the left hates the
most
um especially when it comes to the
younger republican representatives in
congress
and these
photos went viral of madison cawthorne
who's
appears to be a few years ago
wearing lingerie and he's got he's got
other girls with him and they're taking
a selfie and there's no other context
this is the context though according to
katherine politico reported the
revelation of the two photos is the
latest in a series of unflattering
headlines for the freshman member of
congress in the run-up to the primary in
his first re-election bid clawthorne has
seven republican opponents who see him
as vulnerable the photos were provided
to politico by a person formerly close
to call thorn in his campaign and were
confirmed by a second source who also
was a formerly close to the first term
congressman catherine responded to the
report by claiming that the photos were
taken during a vacation cruise
he said quote i guess the left thinks
goofy vacation photos during a game on a
cruise taken way before i ran for
congress is going to hurt me somehow
they're running out of things to throw
at me
and so that's his defenses that they
were just probably drinking and they
were goofing off and that's it was
supposed to be a joke
what you can see here is number one
once again the left completely
abandoning at least temporarily
it's views on
uh the gender binary and everything else
like according to them
there's actually nothing strange at all
about a man wearing lingerie
and certainly to shame somebody for that
to shame them is it that's unspeakable
that's what they say until they have
this as ammunition that they can shoot
at at uh madison hawthorne and then all
of a sudden it's okay
and the other point too is that
if there could be a correct context
for men to wear women's clothing
which
there isn't
but if there was
like it's this it's a joke it's supposed
to be a joke it's silly it's
ridiculous i wouldn't recommend it even
as a joke
but that's actually it's it's
you you find pictures of a man wearing
wearing women's clothing and it's a joke
it's like
this is what they used to do in
hollywood it used to be a punch line
when a man wears women's clothing misses
doubtfire
which somehow that movie has yet to be
canceled by the left eventually they'll
get around to it
because mrs doubtfire it's a comedy and
all of the humor is found in the fact
that robin williams is dressing up like
a woman and ha ha isn't that so silly
and ridiculous
so that's one thing like yes it's silly
and ridiculous and we can laugh about
that
the problem on the left is that they
want to take that and now we're supposed
to take it seriously as a lifestyle
choice
until republican congressmen are
involved and then of course the rules
change completely
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
um four-door 455
this kind of works what we were just
talking about says i worked with a
cross-dressing man and all i can say is
that if a woman employee dressed the way
he did
she would have been accused of violating
the dress code but if you're trans
then i guess you become immune from a
trip to the hr office
yet another way that the rules kind of
are adjusted depending on your identity
and your demographic
mr mediocre gamer says desmond
absolutely sounds like a child i don't
mean just in his voice i mean immaturity
as well the poor kid is not in control
of who he's presented as this child is
going to need a lot of therapy later in
life and mom and dad won't be around to
pay for it
um
well here's the thing i can guarantee
you that this kid has gotten a lot of
therapy already that's part of the
problem
he's gotten a lot of therapy a lot of
counseling but he's going to
the gender affirming therapies
therapists and counselors and they're
just encouraging more of this
so just like we talked about how it's
you can't trust the medical profession
anymore that includes especially in fact
uh therapists and counselors
i mean you can't you can't trust them
with your kids at all
which is
quite a problem because there are kids
who could actually use
that kind of help
but these days you just you know you
send your kid to a counselor and um a
week later they're telling you that they
were born in the wrong body because this
is the kind of thing they're going to
hear but yeah that is one thing that
jumps out at you when you hear
desmond is that he sounds well he sounds
not just like a child but also in a lot
of these videos he sounds drugged as
well
he sounds like a drugged child because
that's what he
is um
mitso says as far as the stooping to
their level comment i agree with matt
100 the organized battle lines of
classic warfare cannot hold up against
the more modern guerrilla tactics so
using them strictly on principle will
only lead to very principled defeat it's
important to still have moral lines that
you don't cross but you can change
tactics and still maintain those
boundaries
uh i think that's exactly right that's
this conservative attitude
establishment whatever you want to call
the old right whatever label you want to
put on it
um
i think if you were to summarize their
position
you couldn't do a better job than that
principle defeat that's what they stand
for
is that we're going to lose and we're
going to keep losing but we're going to
we're going to do it in a principled way
and as we've talked about that's for
them it's it's a it's a lot easier
actually
it's a lot easier it is in fact easier
to lose
because when you're winning and you're
taking
in you're
you're doing big things you're taking
risks and you're doing bold things
well now there's a lot of pressure
i mean look at elon musk taking over
twitter
even as the richest man in the world
uh he's not just putting a lot of money
on the line he's putting he's putting a
lot more than that on the line
and it's not just like okay he's going
to take over twitter and then right off
into the sunset and uh
happily ever after now you actually have
control of twitter
and you have to figure out all the
problems and fix them
it would have been a lot easier
to just
do nothing
and let twitter remain in the hands of
the people that already controlled it
and that's kind of the attitude of of
the establishment right the old right is
uh let's just do nothing at all let
things continue we kind of we have our
lane here
and it's easy and it's comfortable and
we'll just stick with that
that's their attitude you know people
ask me all the time how do i get a job
at the daily wire and i always tell them
well don't don't start by talking to me
that's the first step you're already
already on the wrong foot um but here's
i can for once actually tell you about a
new job at the daily wire for all you
graphic design folks out there who have
been waiting for your chance to work on
staff of the daily wire here it is we're
currently looking for a superb and
creative junior graphic designer to join
our post-production team in nashville
tennessee in this position you'll be
responsible for creating visual concepts
to communicate ideas that inspire inform
and captivate our audience and consumers
ideal candidates for this opportunity
have one plus years of
previous professional design experience
in photoshop or illustrator excellent
creative instincts and a strong team
player attitude to apply for this junior
graphic design opportunity and to view a
full list of current openings at daily
wire please visit
dailywire.com careers that's where you
want to go and you know i've already
told you about this but i'll tell you
again if you've been living under a rock
you might be unaware that i've written a
children's book if you weren't listening
to the first part of the show also you
wouldn't be aware of that and it's
changing the world as we know it it sold
out in less than 24 hours and at one
point was crowned the number one
best-selling lgbtq plus book on amazon
the book is called johnny the walrus
and uh it's has already served as an
inspiration for lgbtq plus people and
that will be the case for centuries to
come i believe as mentioned the book
sold out right away due to its immense
popularity but i have great news the
book is back it's in stock right now
and that's why again you can get the
book and they'll actually
mail it to you you'll get it like the
next day or a day later you don't have
to wait six months this time so if you
want to get the book go to
johnnythewalrus.com and order your copy
right now now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
as we know and have discussed at grade
length
lots of children's entertainment these
days is packaged up with veiled and
often not so veiled leftist
indoctrination
but every once in a while a new piece of
children's content is released that
appears to have no
sinister underlying agenda it's just
innocent benign fun
now i haven't seen it but as far as i
know and have been told the newly
released animated film the bad guys
falls into that category
i haven't heard of any wokeness
infiltrating it don't quote me on that
though like i said i haven't seen it but
that's as far as i know
assuming that it's just a good bit of a
political family fun
it's all the more unfortunate that our
culture has decided to make it weird
because even non-weird things in our
society are made weird the leftist virus
infects everything and that brings us to
an article in rolling stone with a
headline that um
i can't read out loud but which refers
to the reproductive organ of one of the
cartoon characters in the film and the
article begins with this
with his broad shoulders revolving
wardrobe of crisp well fitted suits and
rakish come-hither expressions
mr wolf the slick protagonist of the
upcoming dreamworks release the bad guys
looks like a classic american male sex
symbol in the grand tradition of cary
grant harrison ford and brad pitt
now i need to pause here and say that
though i'm not an expert on american
male sex symbols despite arguably being
one myself don't laugh please
i'd always thought that a prerequisite
for becoming a male sex symbol is that
you have to first of all be human
and second of all exist
rolling stone is here to correct the
record though they continue
the character is prompting hordes of
thirsty comments on the internet
quote mr wolfe isn't attracted to you or
anyone else he's in love with me reads
one representative tweet
another is more to the point
when do i get to see mr wolfe from bad
guys penis in the movie
for those interested there's plenty of
fan art on twitter where you can see
just that
now the article provides many examples
of comments like this but perhaps you've
already heard more than enough to get
the point we're then offered this
explanation
quote because mr wolf is an actual wolf
albeit one voiced by reportedly human
actor sam rockwell most of the people
posting about mr wolfe are furries a
term used to describe those who enjoy
dressing up as or drawing
anthropomorphized animals despite most
popular conceptions about furries not
all people in fandom in the fandom
harbor sexual attractions to
anthropomorphized creatures but many of
those currently thirsting after mr wolf
certainly do
now anytime you hear about these furry
creeps you'll always be given the
disclaimer that it's not always sexual
but of course it is i mean the whole
thing is a bizarre disgusting sexual
fetish
as is admitted in the same article
later on a furry lgbt author as he's
described
offers this insight
most people in furry subcultures
remember the shirtless dancing buff
tigers used in zootopia's marketing that
most took to more or less mean hey
furries we know your community has an
eye for masculine forms so to speak and
we undeniably do furry is a nexus for
queer art and queer people and it's one
of the few places in particular where
gay men and masculine queers get to have
some decent representation in our media
and queer men and masculine people are
kind of starving for that
now this missive goes on for a while
longer
and then ends on this note
still in the absence of official furry
recognition from mainstream
entertainment members of the fandom will
likely continue to simp after mr wolfe
without recognition posting one erect
lupine phallus at a time
now
you might hear all of that and think
well these are just a bunch of demented
fringe deviants and you're right
at least you're right about the first
and last adjectives there
but fringe is debatable as this is
rolling stone we're talking about it's
not like i pulled this from some old
tumblr post
as much as rolling stone might have the
quality and content that resemble an old
tumblr post in fact there's a concerted
effort as the article suggests
to give furries
more mainstream acceptance and
representation
and it seems to be working just
yesterday libs of tick tock published
images of a class assignment given to
second graders in austin where they were
told to make their own furry persona
this was all part of culture month at
the school a month where the kids learn
about different cultures you know like
japanese culture and
egyptian culture and
bestiality culture
because that's what this is after all
people who sexually fantasize about
animals even fictional animals
are into bestiality that's what that is
we've sped right past yet another stop
on the slippery slope that the left told
us would never come
they claimed the fact that we were
bigots for even suggesting that it would
get to this point
because for years we said that our
anything goes attitude towards sexuality
would lead to the normalization of
bestiality you know bestiality
then here's rolling stone right on cue
with a glowing profile of people who
fantasize about a cartoon wolf's penis
now many things have led us to this
point
but certainly one of the one of the
principal factors
is the misdirection of shame
now i don't say that we've gotten rid of
shame in our culture certainly not
it's not like the left is
running around claiming that nobody
should ever feel ashamed or that we
shouldn't shame anybody
they love to shame people it's their
favorite pastime
shame has not been eradicated but as i
say it's been misdirected
because now we shame normalcy
we shame common sense we shame healthy
behavior healthy relationships healthy
attitudes
we shame people for committing the sin
of not being degenerate freaks
the actual shame-worthy behavior
is shielded from shame
and that's that's the problem
because in a healthy society people who
feel attracted to animals
would be ashamed of that proclivity
they would never speak of it to anybody
except perhaps a trusted counselor or
spiritual advisor they would do whatever
they could to rid themselves of their
inner demons
they would feel hideously embarrassed as
they should
and that's the way it ought to be now
though they put on costumes and they go
to conventions and they announce
themselves on social media
and then they go out and actually
proselytize encouraging others
especially children to join them in
their freakish lifestyle
this is supposed to be progress but it's
certainly not
that's why we need to bring back shame
bring it back where it belongs
and then we bring back shame into our
culture
if we get to that point
then we'd be in a position where we can
all say to furries
rather than just me saying it
that you're all canceled and we'll leave
it there for today thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire